all right hashtag tommy tom brady do to
be a free agent well what's that faith
there tom that's the first time i've
ever seen him make an unappealing face
in his life i didn't think he was
capable of it i didn't think the botox
allowed his nose to scrunch up like i
but most people will still think it's
handsome though yeah you're probably
right uh his worst faces is better than
our best face no doubt tom brady do to
become a free agent and out of the blue
last night we're gathered at the pft
dinner and this comes through at 6 36
p.m eastern
it's an m.c escher
m.c
the paintings where before you look at
you can't tell what it is
yeah the stairs going up or are they
going down is the water falling up or is
it down or where does it end and where
does it start i can't tell what this is
this is a riddle this is an amazing
photo because you can't tell if he's
walking into gillette stadium or walking
out of gillette stadium and the more i
look at it the more confused i am the
top half of his body looks like it's
walking in the bottom half of his body
looks like it's walking out i feel like
the hands though when you really blow it
up look like he's walking towards the
camera and the other thing i look at is
where that foot is that foot that like
his left foot to us on the picture it's
the right there it looks like it's in
front this is this is cryptic and i
think this is a guy who's really smart
and knows what he's doing right i mean
to me this is one of those things where
you know if i had to put myself in his
shoes or just being around football all
my life with football players and what
they're thinking he doesn't like how
things are going he's not getting the
answers he wants from new england right
now i would imagine that's and so he's
kind of saying like whoa i'm i'm halfway
out the tunnel here right now that's
that's we're we're not going anywhere
right now with our talk and negotiation
or what i'm hearing from new england and
their side and that's a great point
because
other teams may look at this situation
and say why do we want to be the pawn
why do we want to be the team that
becomes the leverage to get a deal done
between tom brady and new england
patriots he's not leaving we don't
believe he's leaving right we're not
even going to entertain the possibility
of pursuing him because we don't think
he's leaving this is the kind of thing
that could get a general manager a head
coach to have a conversation and say
right maybe he is leaving maybe we
should call don yee and have a
hypothetical conversation that never
happened and folks those happen all the
time yes we know that and they're
happening now for guys who are going to
be free agents hypothetical discussions
about what it would take about whether
or not there's interest all this needs
to be done ahead of time peter king was
talking the other day about how the
patriots want an answer from brady three
days before free agency
he will know well before then no one
will know within his circle what he's
going to do he's gonna know in the next
two to three weeks don't you think and i
think i think he's he's hurt a little
right now i think that i think that he's
this is the message
whether he's coming or going this is the
message i'm in play yeah i am in play
right i'm not on the field i'm in the
middle right now and who knows where
it's going to go and it's the open
invitation right to anyone out there to
contact his agent and begin the process
of of hashing out possibilities
ideas
contract numbers whatever it may be and
you know the folks in boston i was on
one of the boston stations that's up
here 98.5 the sports hub with felger and
mazz yesterday and the patriots fans are
wired to blame
robert kraft this falls apart which is
astounding to me astounding the guy's
been with the team for 20 years he's a
free agent
if he doesn't want to be there how can
you blame the owner of the team for him
not wanting to be there and if he
doesn't want to be there for football
reasons it's not robert craft's fault
right it's a bill belichick call well
yeah i mean that's really what it is i
mean first off like you know
fans fans out there i mean yes i mean
robert kraft wants tom brady back
definitely but new england became new
england because they make smart
decisions bill belichick who's coming
towards the end of his like lifeline
right as far as an nfl head coach he
doesn't want to like ruin his last three
or four years or five years as a head
coach because he got put in salary cap
hell from tom brady two either he's only
gonna be around three i think he's got
ten more years well maybe ten right but
either way he's not going to want to
destroy his team you know post tom brady
and just go oh okay damn i can't sign
four or five free agents because we're
still in a salary cap situation from tom
brady this is what made new england
awesome everybody so we can't be mad
that bill belichick wants to continue to
make the organization awesome and yeah
mr kraft is
we know he loves tom brady it's i
respect that about mr kraft more than
anything i think and any other owner in
football how he's had the back of tom
brady and he's constantly there but he's
also a smart owner into where you know
for the better better part of the time
he always lets bill belichick make the
decision he knows he's a master football
mind and i would just have a hard time
thinking bill all right in my heart of
hearts and this is no knowledge or
inside info here
that bill is going to be willing to pay
tom brady some huge one year number or
two year number
that one can put them in the salary cap
issues but two
bills gonna go the play doesn't justify
that number you know just from anybody i
know and of course i know people in new
england and i've been there and all that
that's just not the way things will
operate he's not going to do that he you
know as i've always said if he thinks
you're worth four cents he's not gonna
give you five cents and i i think bill
is gonna look at it and go wait with you
know two years 60 million
and he's going to say but but tom didn't
play like a top 10 quarterback last year
tom did he didn't play like a top 20
quarterbacks
listen
tom
tom is
he's borderline in the top half of
football anymore i would say that is
this just truth of the matter i'm sorry
it doesn't make me proud to say that but
i think from what i saw towards the end
of the year the playoffs things like
that
you know i think roughly yeah he's
probably in the middle somewhere in
football right now you're right it's
somewhere between probably 16 and 20 16
and 21. that's just the reality of the
situation you could still win that way
but it's hard and a guy like belichick
is not going to sit there and just go oh
here's a blank check for everything you
have done and chris here's the other
side of it too at some point they have
to rip the band-aid off of the tom brady
relationship it's got to end exactly
what do you do do you kick the can for
another year or two when you have an
opportunity unprecedented opportunity to
find a free agent quarterback right you
can sign teddy bridgewater you can draft
somebody you can make a play for taysom
hill if you want sure there's a thousand
different ways you can go yeah you could
get philip rivers if you want phillip
rivers as a stop gap while jared stidham
continues to learn yeah the craft right
peter king has been suggesting in not so
subtle terms that andy dalton may be the
next quarterback of the new england
patriots one of those things that he
says it in a way where it feels like
there's maybe
some something there
right knows something that we don't know
right so
there's so many different ways they can
go and if they re-up with tom brady next
year that opportunity may not be there
no this is the perfect time for the
patriots to say look it's going to end
at some point he's not playing until
he's 50. we've seen a regression i'm
just i'm surprised frankly that patriots
fans who i regard as among the smartest
fans in football i agree i get it i
understand it i don't know that casey
just he's a jessica fan though you can't
listen to matt
i'm surprised that they would be
inclined to place blame on anyone other
than tom brady for choosing to leave and
if it's not tom brady you put the blame
on bill belichick and the x factor in
all of this
is mrs brady yeah no and you've said
that from the start i agree with you and
there's nothing wrong with that yeah
there is nothing wrong overlook the fact
that she has tolerated tom brady playing
well beyond the normal football
expiration date and he keeps going one
more year and one more year and one more
year and at some point what she wants
where she wants to live where she wants
to be where she wants to raise her
family becomes a factor right and we
don't know it's not like she's going to
come out and say so but behind the
curtain that's got to be one of the
factors i feel like new england fans
okay and i'm with you and i've said this
and i know new england fans don't think
i like the patriots and brady and all
that it's just false okay but i do feel
like new england fans are almost willing
to sacrifice the strength or the
goodness of the team to protect
brittany's legacy right as compared to
the 49ers where i was like yeah we don't
want to see joe montana go but we know
steve young's awesome and we're going to
win more super bowls with him right so
they'd rather keep brady and be a team
that gets bounced out of the wild card
round of the playoffs then have brady go
somewhere else and potentially add to
his legacy with another team i feel like
that to a degree or not like let the
patriots be successful without brady
there i don't know if they like that
either and we'll be right back with pft
right after this well done thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports